Wow, I switched.
Oh, you already swung my god.
By the way, Mint did not do the tutorial, so that's why we're here.
That's what we're about to do.
Play tutorial, everybody.
I did do the tutorial.
I'm really only waiting for all of you guys to do the tutorial.
Scroll to equip my torch.
What's my torch?
You did it.
Oh, you go up to the goblin.
He just, he just, like, snaps around.
Ooh.
Yeah, he just goes.
No, everyone else did the tutorial.
everyone else didn't do the tutorial no Lymo's doing it right now I said everyone else didn't do the tutorial I'm doing it right now oh he's talking to me but I'm like not listening oh my god Snuffy's also doing the tutorial right now okay see this is fine wait what does he want me to do oh shoot you just oh hold to light you can literally just skip all everything he's saying what's a brazier is this oh okay know oh my god i'm here hi livo i love the tutorial you will see flagpole oh wait oh i have her at zero oh she oh she does no she muted herself she doesn't have no hi okay mike's muted no no i i still had you guys muted from peak and i was like yeah actually talking or not so i was fixing it
sorry limel no it's it's side i really i really enjoyed the fucking monte python tutorial dude he's wonderful i love him so much he's such a he's just a little guy he's kind of funny i like him all right for those who are like every for the chat who are just like trying to adjust the audio right now um we're all going to be using in game voice chat later yeah yeah so i'm not i'm not going to bounce it too heavily right now yeah me too yeah wait uh you will not be resurrected recall your base by pressing three i'm just adjusting the foggy stuff right now there's like little dead frogs on the ground wait can i pick that up yeah oh grasp the toad it's to help you maintain control of your flagpole i will resurrect the foggy oh i like your food you know toky oh yeah thank you yeah it's cute it added does it animate because sometimes it doesn't work oh there you are I mean she's kind of like perpetually animating but that's fine too I'm trying yeah actually when I was in like China there was
like a the taxis or the ubers or they're called ditties it would have like the TVs at the back and then they're always playing the Chikawa shorts I thought there was like substance to Chikawa shorts, but it's literally like, have any of you guys watched the Chikawa shorts?
There is substance.
What are you talking about?
Literally, okay, the first short I saw from it is literally like, the bunny makes a giant pizza, and then she shares it with Chikawa, and then the short ends.
Why is it substance?
It was like, that was like four minutes, too.
It was like, a frog spear by placing each yeah it's about friendship joki and like demons wait what what explain you mean yeah you have to watch do i have to have to it's like every episode is a filler until like episode 13 where like a demon shows up and kills shikawa's mom and now he's all on a mission to avenge him place item hold on i'm making a frog spear oh yeah that was so buggy for me when i was doing fireball it took me fireball fireball oh press one
fireball i cast fireball did you see the accent menu where it's like yo if you're british yeah wait really it did say that on the main menu click accent menu you've got american or indian and that's it why it says british has been disabled or indian wait there's only two accents in the world american and indian yeah they said that the british version wasn't working for anyone so they disabled it it was too hard to understand one oh yeah yeah for some reason it wouldn't it was It's so hard for them to register a hole.
I kept, I was like, hole.
Hole.
It actually worked all first time for me except for freeze.
Everything worked except for hole.
Okay, it worked, it worked, it worked.
It worked.
Hole.
I'm happy for you.
We did it, guys.
Magic Missile.
Nice.
Okay, I may exit the tutorial.
How do I get out?
Yay!
You gotta use your escape muscle.
He told you, dude.
Use your escape muscle.
Oh, my escape muscle.
Draw my lobby, guys.
We are alive, I think, so, you know, don't dox yourself, Snuffy.
Yeah, all of...
I mean, she's live, too.
Also, I think Snuffy had all of us turn down to zero i have snuffy turned down to zero you know i had snuffy on zero but she didn't light up so she can't hear us yeah yeah i don't think she realized that all of us are at zero but we're gonna turn all of us down to zero anyway in the end she doesn't know she lacks critical Does she know?
Does she know?
I'm gonna join your walk.
Hi.
Would you, did you, did you have us at zero?
I was watching you guys just bounce up and down for a little bit.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, we all did that.
We all did that.
It's okay.
We'll turn all of us.
Are we doing that again for this game?
Yeah.
What?
Yeah, we're doing it.
We're at.
Oh, God.
I hear you.
uh in-game vc oh right we have a lobby code don't we okay hold on yeah let me leak it no i mean let me uncapture my games yeah actually don't leak it we don't want anyone saying slurs they'd never i would look at the steam reviews and they're yeah no i was looking at the steam reviews and they're like yeah people are saying slurs now and i know no which which mode are we doing by the way oh i mean there's only there's only one well there's two modes one's a 1v1 and the other's team so oh it says capture the flag or death match apparently yeah but death match is a 1v1 oh yeah so um so we're doing the normal we do we'll do medium uh we'll do a medium size first because i don't know how big it is are we supposed to hear each other right now in the lobby no no no no okay i can recapture the game right i don't have the lobby idea revealed so it should be fine Yeah,
we're in.
Yeah, we're in.
I'm generating the world.
Okay.
And now we join.
I'm, wait, I want to be a wizard.
I'm a sorcerer.
Okay.
All right.
I smell.
Okay.
Guess we're at each other's team.
You want to say anything that Stuffy's in?
You...
Stuffy, it's not you.
I just wanted to be on a team with Live, but now you're gonna win.
It's not you.
I've been with anybody.
No, no, no.
I've got the word hybrid accent.
I'm gonna confuse the shit out of the game.
It's gonna be awful.
I tried to say magic missile.
It didn't work.
When I opened the VC and we were waiting for you two, I was like, oh, it's okay.
snuffy's not doing a tutorial yet you don't have to do the tutorial and then it was like no I don't want to be like that's not what I said no it's just things of us as like we're two wrong directions we need to like hold somebody else's hey snuffy you we we are copy barra people we're not the gamer people it's true we can't have a repeat of you it's okay we'll We'll just switch up teams every round.
It'll be fine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Steffy, remember, it's not you, Steffy.
It's not you, Steffy.
It's us.
She hates me for my whimsy.
It's okay.
Okay, so apparently you can change our maps so we can edit our map and everything.
Wait, if I draw on our map, Mint, do you see me drawing on our map?
Oh my god, you can draw on the team flag.
I see yeah, I see that Why'd you pick like shit green?
Wait, we can edit a team flag?
Oh Jesus Oh my god, can you see it?
Oh my god, I'm gonna do something.
Oh, I'm cooking.
We can't erase it.
We have to reach it.
No, you can, you can, you can.
You're erasing it right now.
Yeah, no, I have to use the white brush.
Okay, what are you drawing?
Oh, one's bigger than the other.
Sorry.
Oh my god!
What have you done?
What did you do?
Oh, wait, we can make him sands on your tail.
Big fireball was on the flag.
I'm sorry.
Oh, it's not that you're making such a beautiful flag.
Thank you.
Wait, hold on.
I'm going to get a reference.
Drawing, okay, this is gonna be, you get it, it's Liemann, right?
Okay.
Oh, yeah?
What the fuck is Liemann?
What?
You don't know Liemann.
Liemann is my mascot.
Oh, Liemann.
I'm not sure.
I'm trying.
I'm parsing it right now.
I totally, I see the vision.
I see the vision.
I kind of forget what he looks like a little bit.
I think he has a green thing here, and he's just like...
I mean, I don't think he's got any blue on him, but let's go.
That's my...
Okay, that's where I come in.
Oh, wait.
Fuck, that was too big.
All right.
This has been Liemann.
It sounds like you guys have a good thing going.
Stop erasing it.
Oh, no.
We, we, we, I immediately drew a dick and Snuffy got kind of upset about it.
That's just not very wizardry.
No.
I think this is good, though.
The Magister Wimsy was just gone.
We got our flag down.
Yeah, we got ours.
save it to disc honestly snuffy's putting so much effort into this i think all right you save our flag i did all right our flag's good to go you're not gonna cry yeah yeah yeah lemon's base color is white if that helps snuffy i just didn't i was hoping for like a light cream but there was yeah you know you made him piss he's like piss man now piss man he's like lemon lemon he
all right i can't i believe in us man i i believe i believe i can say whole yeah i can also say whole let's select the magic word whole oh man all right are you all ready i'll start the game okay i'm gonna lower everyone's volumes and don't say anything important from now bye Bye!
It's time.
Hello?
Okay.
Is there a flag up there?
Oh, yeah!
Wait, it's just white!
What?
I forgot to save it!
You didn't save it!
I forgot.
It's just a white flag.
Oh, for you, you forgot to save it.
Yeah, I thought, because you saved it, that But I would see it.
Oh, no.
Wait, let me push.
I'm going to up the volume for the voice real fast.
Okay.
You keep cutting out in and out.
I think it's kind of janky.
Is it better now?
Yeah.
No, yours is fine from my end.
Oh, okay, cool.
Is it better now or no?
Yeah, yeah.
Yours is much better.
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, so you press escape.
You can, like, adjust the audio on the top left.
Or like other people.
Oh, we gotta get our...
Sands loaded in!
Oh, nice!
I see it!
There he is!
I see Sands!
You see Sands?
Yeah, I saw him from the beginning.
Wait, I don't hear you.
Oh, I actually lowered you all the way down.
Okay.
I hear you now.
I can hear you now.
Oh!
What?
What was that?
What did you do?
Stop!
Oh my god, I'm about to die!
Oh my god, where am I?
I've been respawning.
Oh wow, it's like a little elf village.
Is there... Oh, there is stamina in this game, okay.
Um...
Can I equip my... Okay, good.
Just in case.
Oh wow, there's people here.
Hello?
Oh, they're so small.
I have nothing to trade.
Greetings.
I think I hear her.
Doki?
I heard her.
I heard her talking.
Where am I?
Is this the afterlife?
It's different than what I...
No.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Boing.
I'm gonna get that one.
I'm gonna get this.
Oh, shit.
I missed.
It's fine.
There's no fall damage.
Oh, my gosh.
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Is this how you're supposed to play the game or...
Whose flag is this?
Oh, that's mine!
Wait, I'm so confused!
What's happening?
What?
A boing?
What's that over there?
It does sound like a stomach, huh?
The sorcerers have captured the Forest Hills.
What?
What is this game?
I don't know anything about this, you guys.
Oh, shoot.
A mist.
Boing is happening.
Boing.
Okay, hold on.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, yeah, that's what we're talking about, baby.
The Forest Hills...
Fireball.
What is this thing?
What do you have that?
What is that?
He's way smaller than I thought.
Fireball.
What do you say?
I keep hearing Doki!
Am I crazy?
My spell gross.
Doki, can you hear me?
Can you hear me?
Hi!
Doki!
Fireball!
Oh wait, that's you!
That's you!
Oh, stop, stop!
Magic missile!
What just happened?
I think...
wait why are they here all the sudden what's the what's the spell oh there's fireball freeze I didn't mean to do that but they're right over here wait everybody's here it's one map I thought I was in like the afterlife where
are talking oh my gosh it's so dark why is it so dark i
can't see anything
they're in i'm wearing my headphones backwards i was like i hear them in my left ear that's why i kept turning around oh my god freeze freeze oh god where's magic missile magic missile magic okay freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze freeze i'm going back freeze magic missile freeze
Um, truce?
Fireball.
Fine.
Magic missile.
Fireball.
Why are those so dodgeable, Daisy?
It hates me!
It hates my accent!
Ah!
Hey.
Wait!
She died!
Oh!
No, I didn't.
I'm fine.
Seems to be a cooldown, but how long?
It's like the longest cooldown ever.
I'm trying, I'm speaking all calm, cool, collected.
It does not understand my accent.
It glows when it's ready.
Okay, I'll remember that.
Whoa, whoa!
Where did I get into a cave?
Why did Doki leave me?
The sorcerers have captured the mushroom biome.
That's my, that's where I captured.
A warlock has been slain.
Fireball!
Oh my god, she's at their base!
What the fuck?
You!
A traitor is...
Fireball!
Wham!
Where'd you go?
Fireball!
Wham!
Did I miss?
Fireball!
Ah!
Freeze!
Fireball!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Where are you?
Magic missile.
Please think of the mushroom village.
Fireball.
Why does it work for you?
Everybody, please.
It does understand British accents.
Wait, do we press play again?
Hello?
One spudderbubber.
This is why I wanted to be on Lyme's team.
Wait, how do we...
I don't think it's gonna work if we don't hear it.
Overall, wait, what's...
Hello?
Bring- Bring- Hi!
Bring down what sound?
Mons, what do you mean by that?
Oh, just the effects?
We have to remake Lobby every time?
Oh, I can't do that now.
Wait, wait.
Ima just said that.
No, no, you click.
No, you click.
What are you talking about?
Play it again and we're in the same lobby.
You guys all sound crazy.
I don't know who has food.
I know, I can't tell either.
Apparently it's fine.
Okay, sound effects down and overall up.
I'm muting Doki again.
She just talks too much.
All right, we just gotta wait for that.
She's mansplaining.
Oh.
I joined that was so funny yeah there oh my god yeah we yes okay I'm gonna mute everybody again this is so confusing so basically guys we have everybody muted in discord so that our Fugies still work but now we don't we can't communicate in the we can't communicate in the in the The thing!
Wait, what should we make?
Uh, I'm gonna say Lymo.
Lymo.
The game?
There's no invoice chat in the...
Oh, she's riding.
She's communicating.
It's like a spirit.
Wait.
It's like a spirit bot...
Or a Ouija board.
Except I would...
I should be the one controlling it.
M?
Okay.
L.
This is so cute!
Mario plus Luigi.
Wait, that's so smart.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna draw their hats.
Mario hat.
And Luigi hat.
Why
is it so bad?
There we go.
Mario plus Luigi.
Save.
Brothers.
Yeah, people come.
Me and Limeu mojito.
I've seen that before.
We're mojito.
How do we know when we start?
Start whenever...
Oh, Jesus!
Ah!
Nice!
Very good, very good.
Oh, yeah, so... What's in here?
What you did last time is if you take...
Now we have a grass crystal.
I don't know what that is.
I'm going to combine mine with a log and see what happens.
Okay.
I definitely did not get this because Doki killed me before I could even make anything.
Yeah, we were just sitting there and we just saw, like, Doki kill you immediately.
It was like, okay, fine.
Yeah.
I don't know what Doki up does, but, like, we made something.
That's cool.
How do I...
How do I drop an item?
What was it, E?
No?
Oh, G.
He's made an ingredient, and I'll make you a powerful magical soup.
Soup?
Oh, he wants an ingredient to make a powerful magical soup.
What about these mushrooms?
Would you like, is this, make frog soup.
I'm making frog soup.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
Ew.
Your turn.
Oh, I got it.
Oh, do I drink this?
You go for it.
My tongue gains a mind of its own.
Oh no!
You touched me with your tongue!
I'm gonna try of the soul, the staff.
I do not get that, I'm stuck on the stairs!
Okay.
What does it do?
Okay, okay, okay.
Doesn't do anything.
Gen- genuinely, your tongue came out and smacked me, I don't know.
Oh, freaky!
Oh, stop?
Oh, of course.
Oh my god, dokey!
Mirror, me- Oh wait!
Oh!
Whoa!
That's all done!
How'd you do that?
I clicked on you with it.
Oh, okay.
I can show you the word.
Oh!
Wait, that's freaky.
Laimo, upies, upies, like, woo!
Yeah!
Bounce on it.
Dio.
How do you get out of here?
Oh, you...
can either like use a bounce mushroom maybe or otherwise you you press e on this oh okay yeah i don't i just gotta close it afterwards because otherwise they'll walk right in right oh wow i'm finally seeing the world isn't exciting can i levitate this bird that's what i was thinking no you cannot levitate the bird i'm ready to levitate somebody also dokey can't shut up so it's really easy to find her i know
oh fireball fireball
freeze oh my god
okay I have this magic missile fireball
fireball magic missile good job Good job, Laiwu!
It's kind of OP, actually.
That was stupid.
Quick, run!
I can't believe that worked.
Magic missile!
Fireball.
Ow!
Wait, I can't use my...
Oh, I can.
Freeze.
Oh.
She's still frozen, though.
Magic missile.
Fuck, I put my book away!
magic missile
nice freeze magic missile she's just yeah I hear her she's behind us I hear her I hear her I'm gonna try and open the thing okay
opening opening opening what is that what is this thing what is this thing Crap.
Fireball.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
Sorry, fireball.
Oh, God.
I died.
No, I lost some of my stuff.
I don't know how to get back home.
Guys, wait.
This looks different than before, no?
Go Lymo.
She's so good at this game.
Wait, am I going into darkness?
Oh.
I'm getting all blown around.
Beek it.
Magic!
Fireball!
Why doesn't it work?
That didn't work.
Why didn't it work for me?
I'm a hero.
Fireball.
I just keep saying fireball I can't move my Oh I believe in Limu I don't believe in Doki It's okay She's so calm and cool And collect Fireball Fireball Fireball It works in the tutorial Magic missile.
I can't see anything.
Oh my gosh.
We'll look at Lymo.
Fireball.
Oh shit!
Magic missile.
Try to reset voice.
Okay, I tried.
I tried.
Oh, stuffy's dead.
Fireball!
Our spells only go stronger!
Magic missile!
Oh shit!
I liked using my staff though, that was really cool.
Fireball!
Oh!
How much?
I can't see what Doki's at.
Magic missile!
Oh sorry, fireball!
I cast fireball!
Yeah, the staff works so well.
My elbow was...
Fireball!
Oh shit!
This is so slow.
Magic missile!
Oh!
Free!
Yeah!
It's lifelight all over again!
Yay!
Oh.
leaving ah
i miss my staff make it level three what does that mean us versus lime oh true actually yeah oh one v3 i thought i said level three now we are level two lackey soon i will be level 100 mafia boss i think uh oh i think lime was game
Lime, because I said that she was playing again.
The music stopped.
Level 100, Mafia boss.
I will control the whole Yakuza.
Kabuki-cho will be in my grasp.
Are we talking to each other?
Actually, yeah.
Alice's lobby is full.
No!
Lime's game did crash.
you muted everyone yeah because we all muted each other i i explained it earlier you guys i don't know who's unmuting though i'll unmute register my voice like doesn't register my accent i'm literally speaking with an american accent how much more american the game want from me Is Doki still muted?
Oh yeah.
She killed Minto until her job is haunting the server.
It's discrimination.
It's discrimination against me and only me.
Hi, Lyman.
Hi.
I was like the only one that was unmuted and everyone was just like a stream of consciousness and it was like burr.
I didn't think anybody else was unmuting so I was like, well, but since your game crashed, I was like, okay, we should discuss.
the others are they talking to us yet are they just talking no they were just talking okay i'm gonna leave the lobby then maybe yeah i can't get back in it says it's like it says it's full i guess because it still counts me in there or something so i i will have to remake it dokey unmute unmuted you're unmuted yeah okay uh it crashed we were yapping yeah exactly
uh okay am i making a new lobby yeah yeah please it says the lobby's full when i try and join now all right i'll make a new lobby all right okay okay we're 3v1ing 3v1ing i remember you're plotting while you were while you were muted i was like no it's like it's literally the only way don't don't leak the code don't leak the code not leaking the code sorry friends join all right we just need yeah all right i make i start lobby all right i'm gonna die away from us uh i'm muting everybody i'm muting everybody bye everyone oh wait i'm muting libu only i'll make my flag as well and it'll be cooling no i'm gonna i'm gonna listen to all right all right here you go oh wait who do i join a warlocks the warlocks all right let's make our flags guys let's make our flags it's fine i'll just cry who is making this what the i'm not drawing okay who is the purple and who is the gray what are you trying to convey with that but i want to be like kill libel I don't think I'm gonna
draw a knife with blood on it yeah i'll add the blood yeah yeah there you go
same to this flag if she even changes it i don't even know what she would be just a smiling face i drew a sad face
look at her eyes we have like red glowing eyes i don't know We're so scared.
I'm done.
I drew a sad face and that's it.
I'm starting the game.
Okay.
I'm using a Meet 7 TV mode.
Meet Hi.
Hello, team.
Oh, my God.
Doki Bird, stop killing everybody.
Okay.
I won't kill anybody this time.
I won't.
I will kill my teammates.
I promise.
Oh, dang.
Which is the best?
Up your volume real quick for your mic.
Me?
Yeah, yeah, for your like in-game like for the it goes settings and then do like volume Volume for me Is that your mind or just your whole volume?
Hello?
Yeah, it goes settings and then you go push it all the way up I did it Alright So now if you could also do that too Yes I play Please don't scream in my ears but look what I just made Oh hell yeah it's mushroom man what's a grass walk oh wait that's not what did you make what did you make when you're like firmly grasped snuffy and i it was uh it was the levitation thing how do you make that oh i got a walking stick what the did you make a walk and stick that's it that's all it does i don't know wait it makes you jump it makes you jump try jumping but you're holding it oh it's a polo you have a polo it's a polo stick watch this watch watch watch wait stand here doggie yeah oh what on what does it do jump on what do you what uh bounce on it press g press g yeah then jump on him oh oh my god it's a fall damage it's her fall damage there's no fall there's no fall damage no there's none okay okay that's good that's good oh wait a Oh,
cute!
Oh, cute!
Wait, I'm gonna...
Boink, boink!
I think we should go...
How do we...
How do I find Lyman?
Alright, I'm gonna close our...
Okay, we're gonna...
We have to walk together, guys.
Why don't we have someone protect here?
Yeah, someone should pretend...
Or protect...
Defend?
Um...
I'll pretend to defend.
Okay, yeah, very good.
Alright, I believe in you, Shum.
You got this!
Oh, Chad told me something crazy.
Wait, does it work?
You hold B!
Oh!
Wait, you already knew that?
Yeah, I did that and I teleported and Doki was in my home.
Wait, the mushroom fire.
That is...
I don't know.
That is like you are right.
That's over here.
That's the mushroom fire.
bio where i'm going she's over here
okay oh my god mince fucking bouncing dokey shut up
she's just talking fireball
Fireball.
Why doesn't it work for me?
Oh, it did.
Magic missile.
Oh my god.
Freeze.
I thought that was doki, valued It's a little person, it's a little guy!
No!
Magic missile.
Fireball.
Oh shoot, oh shoot, I'll shoot, I'll shoot.
Oh please!
No please!
Fireball.
I wanna be British!
Freeze.
Oh, wait.
That was right.
Oh shit!
Freeze.
I got her!
Fireball.
She got both of us at the same time!
No way!
Oh my god.
No, my pogo stick.
Where's the... I guess it's a different map every time, huh?
Because I was like, where's the...
I was like, where's the mushrooms?
Is this our place?
I can't tell.
Q for map.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, I was like, where's Snuffy?
Why is she in the corner?
Oh, it's dark.
Is this Snuffy?
Snuffy?
Where's Snuffy?
hi hello i found this i found the piece of excalibur what how the whole ox have captured the sorcerer's base i know i thought it was the whole sword oh the sorcerer's base oh my god wait yoki is flipping doing it yeah she's doing it um what do you yeah you uh put it uh put it in the chest
I wonder where the other pieces are.
I don't know.
Built of Excalibur.
Now I'm going to be obsessed with finding the dang sword.
I'm going to go this way.
Fireball.
Wait, is something happening?
Are people out there?
Yeah.
She is up.
Freeze.
Fireball.
Magic missile.
Freeze.
Oh!
Wow!
I think I think stuff he just killed me.
Oh, no, life killed me.
Life killed me.
How?
Doki bird.
What?
Oh, freeze.
Where are you?
Fireball.
Magic missile.
Freeze.
Nope.
Fireball.
Magic missile.
Magic.
Freeze.
I can't!
I was on the wrong page.
No, it said freeze!
I
think I actually said rock.
Scalabird, tell me when you drop items when you die.
I'm the only one dead.
I tried defending this world.
Climbing
Everest.
What is happening?
He's got drop down.
There's no fall damage.
Okay, now I know what that does.
Okay.
I have this spell.
It doesn't like me.
Is this our flag?
Yeah.
I can save us.
Fireball.
Oh my god.
Rock!
What the hell is rock?
The fuck?
What is that?
Fireball.
Toge is my beak.
Am I not, it doesn't, am I not saying it enunciating enough?
I feel like I enunciate.
It's my accent.
Ooh, graveyard.
Whisp.
What?
Whisp?
Where are people getting these spells from?
Fireball.
What?
Can you stop letting fucking ghosts at me?
What's wrong with you?
Freeze.
Cross.
Fireball.
What is going on?
Freeze.
Damn.
Fireball.
Magic missile.
Oh, freeze.
Fireball.
Yeah.
Lime got six kills on us.
Holy shit.
It's okay.
I thought there was a British Biba.
It's really hard to know who is who.
Once I figure out sorcerers and the difference between wizards and sorcerers, it's easy.
But like, I'm looking at people and I'm like, I can't tell if that's Lime.
How is she an arc mage already?
Okay, what does it help?
Is that it's my accent?
Me neither!
Oh I have to speak so like normally like fireball Fire oh wait does that wait what just happened?
Wait it actually made a fireball Fireball Oh wait we are still playing the game Fireball
Okay Hello Oh, there it goes.
Oh, well, oh.
The game keeps being weird.
I can't believe Lai Vu is...
Lai Vu got six kills on us.
Oh my gosh.
That's how I have to say it.
Yeah, fireball.
Can I...
Pee...
Pee.
Please pee.
No.
I guess if you really need to is what Doki just said
Fireball Fireball Fireball Fireball Oh wait I forgot to turn I'm unmuting people
Can anyone hear me?
Apparently, yeah she keeps She crashes whenever she tries to play again And because of that Like we have to make oh wait no she's back she back oh she's back yeah she's a sputterer oh we're all sputterers oh wait a team flag everyone i will join don't get bird this time no
well that has been raised thank you for this song what if we just did please no
first start oopsie uh i want to know how everything works because by myself i couldn't recapture anything okay oh really oh yeah like you know if i left here it was just gonna be like a feedback group of you guys capturing everything oh right oh and let the games begin okay we gotta snuffy didn't even join a team though yeah i don't think she got in i accidentally pressed play her by herself in the sorcerer no no she's not in the lobby she's not in the game okay okay fireball okay we gotta kill each other yeah we just gotta kill magic missile fireball magic missile let me have one kill can i have one kill
She's cruel!
She's so cruel!
She's so... She's so big!
Is she in there?
Or is this our castle?
Dang it.
Oh!
Hey, you're on my team.
You're here!
Are you guys on my team?
No.
We... Doki accidentally started the game.
killing each other evil we're killing each other don't we're gonna we're gonna you know but I'm I'm coming in real quick I want to see your place oh okay okay fireball ray of shrinking oh look at you you're so small fireball fireball I'm killing you like a bug magic missile fireball Fireball.
Oh, wait, don't kill me, please.
Wait, wait, wait, don't kill me.
Don't kill me.
Truth, truth, truth, truth, truth, truth.
Where are you?
Wait, wait, wait.
You gross.
Fireball.
How do I get big again?
Well, you can take their things.
Ray, I have shrink.
Two warlocks have been sleeping.
What do you mean again?
Hello, anybody?
Whoa.
Can you sink in this?
No.
Wait, what if I make myself small?
Cast ray of small!
Hello?
Wait, can I be loaded in?
Yeah!
Wait.
Can you load it in?
Yeah, but come here.
Oh.
Wait.
I can't get out.
Fireballs.
No!
Freeze.
Oh, freeze.
By the way, I can't help.
Fireballs.
Fireball.
Freeze.
I thought she was saying please, me too.
I didn't know what the heck she was saying.
This game is silly, you guys.
What's down here?
Whoa.
What if I just fall?
Oh, there is fall damage.
Guys, we learned.
My ankles.
My old, my, my grandma ankles.
Ping pong, ping pong.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Ba-ba-ba.
What the hell was that sound?
Oh, it's me walking.
Where is everybody?
Oh my
gosh.
Doki Bird dying.
By Doki Bird.
Well now I know the frog will, you know.
Fireball.
Oh, yeah, you're right.
I can't believe you would just say fireball like that.
Fireball.
okay truce okay truce truce okay truce yeah yeah yeah i got i got eaten by a frog
whoa i think that was just chilling back in the face right now i was i think she she thought stuffy never made it back cool hasn't moved since.
Lymo?
Yeah.
No, she killed.
She has.
What?
She killed.
No, I didn't see her kill anybody.
No, she was here.
She was?
Why is she moving?
Wait, you can shoot?
Fireball.
Oh, Lymo can't respawn because we never claimed our base.
Oh, let's go claim it.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We might fucked up there she's been apparently she's been like watching us wait what's A little guy?
Fireball.
I get it.
Okay.
What
happened?
Oh, but we fucking...
We just killed a child.
What?
What is so loud?
I'm so confused.
How did we win?
I'm gonna play, I'm gonna play again.
Yeah, play again.
What?
Huh?
I'm, why are they lackeys and I'm a novice?
Hmm.
This game is so...
Let's explore the great wizarding world together.
I got bodied by a frog.
Ah!
That happened!
To me too!
Oh, she killed- So it was the timing!
There's secret stuff around the map.
Wait, what's safe for Lyme, though?
Oh, you made a new lobby?
Start, oh wait, actually, we'll do large.
Start lobby.
Okay, we, truce, guys.
Oh, rip.
Truce.
Truce?
We are a team now.
I think she's riding, though.
All right.
Hello?
We are a team.
A team.
What I would like to be on, um...
Of course she wants to be on.
You know what, I'll be on Snuffy's team.
I'll be on Snuffy's team.
Our team flag.
Oh, she's already got it going.
I'm gonna, I know what we're gonna be.
All hail.
King of the losers.
Wait, I think I need to make it a little bit thicker.
E.
R.
S.
We're the king of the losers.
Oh, I thought they wouldn't want a flag that has, like, losers on it.
Oh my god, yes.
Okay, here we go, wait, mint you go.
What?
Check it out.
Yeah?
This small!
Someone told me to make a soup.
This is an ingredient, and I'll make you a powerful magical soup.
Someone told me to make a rock soup.
Yeah, I've never made a soup before.
Okay, let's try it.
I'm gonna eat it.
See how this heals you.
Hello?
It says my voice bellows from the mountaintops.
Wait, why did Doki stab Limu?
You might be very loud.
Like, you might be so loud that your voice is echoing maybe 10 times right now.
Hello?
Uh-oh.
I'm gonna eat rock soup.
Let's, or no, log soup.
She eats rocks.
Wait.
Okay, here we go.
Log soup.
Your skin hardens like tree bark.
Oh my god, I got extra help.
You got extra help.
Oh, I see it.
Am I still loud?
Yes.
Yes, you are.
They might be able to hear you.
You should say names to them.
You should call them names.
I'm gonna say slurs!
YouTube, that's a joke.
I'm going inside the crystal dimension.
Oh, there's a cavern.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going, I'm investigating this cavernous area.
Wait, I thought Doki wanted us to be friends this time.
Should we, should we, should we ask them to come with us?
Wait, I'm gonna go back.
Okay.
B.
Wow!
I'm gonna go ask them if they want to come.
If they don't agree, I'm gonna shrink them so they're not threatening.
Yeah.
Oh, I tried to shrink that bird.
Hello?
We're friends?
Truce?
Truce for real first?
Come in peace?
Peace?
Yes?
Why did you...
Why did you murder Lymu then?
Oh.
Because...
Look, oh no no no no, this is a peace place.
Okay.
It's okay.
It's only for it's only it's for our own safety.
Yeah, you're okay smaller
do it to me i'm small too oh my gosh i'm fast
Yeah, yeah.
The way she just gets her ankles.
Wait, I want that.
No, you took it.
What?
It's the ray of shrinking.
No, don't, don't, don't, no, no, no, don't.
I...
Magic missile.
I'm gonna shake you!
No!
Fireball.
What's this?
She took my pogo.
She took my pogo stick.
I thought we were supposed to
explore.
Yeah, we are.
I can have my stick back.
Am I back to normal height?
They were back to normal.
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Here.
Here's your walk.
You sick.
Oh, thank ya.
Oh, where's Snuffy then?
Why do you have that?
What's my peaceblade?
Okay.
Where's...
Where's Lyme?
I'm in peace.
She's in the middle.
Wait, where's Snuffy on your map?
In the middle?
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Then they're both together.
Let's go to the middle then.
Okay, we'll go to the middle.
Wait.
How do I get out of here?
How the hell do I get?
Oh, there it is.
What the fuck do you mean?
I don't know!
I don't know I was lost!
Yeah, stab in peace.
Stab in peace, okay.
No, you don't stab at all.
You don't stab at all.
Hello?
Wait, guys, guys!
We lost together.
What?
Come in peace.
Hi.
Oh, hey.
I wanted to explore the crystals.
Yeah, let's go explore!
In here, in here.
There's one right here, too.
You sound so insincere right now.
I swear to fuck if you stab me.
Fireball.
I'm right next to you.
Oh, we can like pop fireworks.
Fireball.
Wait, what's going on?
Should I leave the portal here?
Like, like, worm?
Oh, yeah.
And then we'll have multiple portals just in case.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, I'm calling back.
Does anybody have their torch?
I have mine.
And then we jump down.
Don't fall.
There is apparently fall damage.
Oh, there is.
Yeah, I learned that going in here.
I'm getting Dark Souls flashbacks.
I hate this.
Here we go, here we go.
Okay, and then I'm gonna make a hole.
Wait, what's that?
This is one of them.
All there...
Is that...
Was just the...
The hack hole?
Is this the hole?
Yeah, I guess so.
Is this everything?
Oh, no.
I got the hole.
Wait, where are you guys?
I'm in the hole.
I'm here.
Yes, that's all there is.
Dang.
What's over here?
It looked like big old carrots.
Wait, all adults have protection.
Yay!
Crystal cabins.
Oh, this is nothing.
Sorry, finders keepers.
I feel like there's anything here.
They're skeepers.
What about, we got a funny scalabry.
Why don't we get the rest of it?
Scalabry.
I got killed by glitchy skeletons, but I got it from the crypt.
Wait, wait, we can all, like, try...
What?
Why did she go?
Where did she go?
But they're all legal expired, which kind of sucks.
Oh, no!
Wait!
I can't go through!
So yeah, we can just climb up.
Again.
Oh, ouch.
Why?
We can recall with B.
I think that's what she did.
Yeah, yeah, you can go back home with B.
Wait, am I the only one going...
Oh, okay.
Oh.
Bye.
I was just gonna climb out.
It's not that hard.
I did it last time.
It's literally right here.
Everybody's so lazy.
Hello?
I want to go, wait, cue.
To the red all the way on the ride.
Tornado?
I know?
Yeah.
Oh, there you go.
Oh, my gosh.
I went over there and I was like watching some sort of vortex.
It was really weird.
Let's check it out.
Oh, wait.
There's a mountain.
Yeah, there's a mountain here.
Whoa.
Oh, my gosh.
It's really windy.
Yes, we're having a deal here.
A worm.
But our holes expire.
They do.
Oh!
Stuffy!
Oh no!
I'm okay.
Oh, you're still here.
Wait, wait.
Hold.
Oh no, a frog ate Lymo.
Oh no.
That's so nice.
Oh my gosh.
But there's another...
There's another passageway over here.
I got back up.
Mid-phantom frog dokeybird.
Wait, how?
What?
How did I just frog dokeybird?
How did that happen?
I killed somebody.
Oh, this is just a separate way up, I think.
Are you up the top?
There was nothing up there except the flag.
You have to go all the way up here for a flag?
That's crazy.
Yeah.
I killed a person.
I killed Doki somehow as a frog.
Oh, in here.
Wait.
Okay.
Do you guys want to explore a creepy tomb together?
Yes, yes.
I've always wanted to explore a creepy tomb.
Oh, boy, do I?
That's my afterlife's wish.
Yeah, there's some creepy skeletons in here, so we gotta be careful.
Wait, like harm, they move and...
Oh, enter mausoleum.
How do I get in?
Oh, here we go.
Stable geometry.
It might even be spooky scary skeletons.
Spooky scary skeletons.
And shivers down my spine.
What was that sound?
Are they doing magic?
They are here.
Oh my gosh.
I can't see anything though.
I'll keep my thing out.
My torch.
Sounds good.
Oh yeah, there's an NPC wandering around who will attack us, I think.
Can you go slightly ahead?
Oh, he's still exceeding me.
Can you shine a light for me?
Yeah.
There he is.
Oh!
Magic missile!
There's only... Oh!
Oh!
Oh, oh, I'm nothing without you, Lai-Mu.
I'm nothing without you, Lai-Mu.
I can't do this on my own!
Hello?
I'll wait for her.
How am I almost dead?
Hello?
Oh, hey!
What happened to the other haters?
Uh, Lai-Mu is in there exploring.
Do you want to go help her?
Where is she?
Yeah, what's this?
Have you tried in the soup before?
No, what is that?
Oh.
What happened?
Hello.
Hi.
Okay, do you still have your sword?
No.
My peace sword got eaten.
No, not eaten.
There's like NPCs down there that I think would be better if we had swords.
Oh, really?
Oh.
Yeah.
Okay, I drank a magic potion.
So I should be really strong now.
Oh.
What does the magic potion do?
Go in there and fight him.
I'll back you up with my torch.
Okay, let's go.
I believe in Doki.
Alright.
Alright, go on down.
Ow.
What do you mean, ow?
Spooky, scary, skeletons, and shivers on your small world's side.
Alright, keep going.
Ouch.
That was a choice.
Ouch!
I'm gonna die.
Goodbye, cruel world!
Oh, I lived.
I'm okay, I'm okay.
I died.
What happened?
Um, oh, they're in the middle.
Wait, I can get to the red world from here.
Is that the red world over there?
Yes.
Red world, red world, red world, red world.
My spells are growing stronger.
Wait, so there's actual other enemy...
Wait.
Oh, I think this is our home.
No.
I think Snuffy's at our home.
Oh, this is their home.
Oh, I understand now.
I'm learning more.
Crystal.
I think Pokemon's on its own.
I'm kind of mad.
What was that?
This
is what I sounded like earlier.
Baby bird.
I'm just gonna keep eating soup.
I don't know what it does, but I think I'm becoming stronger.
I think I'm becoming stronger.
Donkey bird, are you that crow talking to me?
Gosh.
I'm feeling full of soup.
What are you bringing, little guy?
More crystals?
else.
I hunger, I crave a delicious meal.
I like how there's just like cut up trees and stuff around.
How do you find the Excaliburs and things?
Yeah I'm full of soup.
I'm full of soup.
Can you die in the fire?
I'm guessing you can.
Excaliburs in the really wait what's this place oh I'm in the inferno I can I can make it hello
team hi hi we're trying to we're trying to find items to treat to the goblins I'm actually given by torch oh wait there's like a ton of crystals by your by your place oh yeah you know i killed a bunch of kids oh are you supposed to kill the kids yeah and rob them oh i think i was still in that the mausoleum oh yeah i'm going in yeah oh my god are you here i'm in here your wizard entourage has arrived here?
A spell?
Oh, you got it?
Yeah, I got it.
Whoa!
Divine light.
Whoa.
It's cool.
And everyone goes, oh.
Looks good.
Oh my god, all I have to do is do that.
Whoops, sorry sound guy.
Is this the...
Can I make soup?
No.
Now you can actually balance the game for me.
For real.
Anything else in here worth taking?
I found, I also got stuck in this room going round and round in a loop for like a minute and shot off Debbie.
Oh wait.
How do I break this?
I don't know.
Oh, I found it.
I found another ace of Excalibur, you guys.
Why are you on fire?
Wait, why am I burning?
Oh my goodness.
Wait, let me test something.
I got it.
I don't think so.
How did that get burned?
Is there another one?
Hey, don't burn me!
Magic missile.
Oh wait, I'm on fireball.
Ouch!
Oh.
Magic missile.
Why am I a fire against?
Stop burning me!
Come here.
No, it's an item.
Okay.
So how do we craft the blade?
I would assume you go back to the altar and put the two pieces on.
I think I'm burning tea.
I'm going all on fire.
Freeze!
Snuffy!
Wait, so there's more in here?
You can make that thing!
If we killed the skellies, that means there's more stuff, no?
Loot?
Nothing, just skellies?
That lame.
I'm lost.
Stop it!
Hey, Snuffy, which base are you going to?
too, because I'll come with you.
Yeah, I would think...
Yeah, put the two pieces in the altar, probably.
Is there, like, a wild crafting bench you can use?
No, I don't think so.
I haven't seen one.
I think I'm on a different base.
I will walk and escort you to my house, to my wizard.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go.
Yeah.
Maybe we'll bump into the children.
Sorry if it's, like, kind of messy.
We haven't cleaned up, you know.
Stop!
Stop it!
Design light!
Whoa!
Not punished!
I'm not a pyromaniac, I swear.
Rock!
Okay, let me put this on here.
Now put the other part on there.
Whoa!
Can I murder someone in the name of science?
Me!
I nominate men.
That was good.
I can't even let this go.
I'm like stuck.
He was just pointing it.
Can you hold...
Wait.
No.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I've recovered.
I've recovered.
Here you go.
Next time she sets you on fire, Mint.
Thank you!
You're welcome.
I like how it strikes lightning down when you die.
I know.
It's really epic.
Don't tell her you have it.
It'll be funny.
Like hide it and then when she tries.
What are you snacking on?
I drank soup!
I wonder why we're doing that.
Is Doki alive?
I don't see her on the mat.
Yeah, yeah.
She will respawn.
She's coming.
I could see her.
Oh, okay.
I respawned from it.
I came to hell.
Wait.
Hello.
Wait, did you drink that potion?
I could hear you from all the...
Oh.
What?
He just crashed in the air.
Divine light.
Divine light made the kids go yeah!
Yeah, oh no, it's because you got our flag.
Yeah, I got the flag.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll take it back now.
I'll take it back.
Oh, our flag that has nothing on it.
Complaining.
I think this is broken.
Why can't I just paint this story?
Why?
Huh?
She still got me on fire before I killed her.
I fell into it for once.
Oh no.
What have I done?
Divine light.
What's that?
I got two rounds together and made me cry.
These shit!
We were, what are you doing?
We're your own fucking megaphone.
Oh,
more rocks!
More rocks!
I got more rocks.
What's up here?
Is Excalibur the only thing you can get in this game?
Like...
No,
when you guys are 3B1ing me, Snuffy managed to find a spell that costs like wisps that tracked me through the entire fucking map.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
And we have a spell that made rocks, like, explode and then killed herself with it.
Yeah.
Yeah, that sounds all right.
That sounds, yeah.
Wait, why can't I draw it?
There we go.
Let's go to the top of this.
Wait, Limu, can I...
Can I Sephiroth you?
Yeah.
Just take my divine light afterwards.
Oh, no, actually, I don't want to... here.
Oh, yeah, I made it.
Wap, wap, wap, wap.
Oh.
Yeah.
Divine light.
Wait, how do I use this?
Oh, divine light.
Divine light.
I feel so blessed.
I have this drumming thing, but I don't know what this does.
That's what, that's what, uh, Snuffy's been using.
Wait a second.
What does it do?
Try, use it, use it.
Oh, wait.
Hello?
I use it.
Oh, I don't think it works.
I don't think it works because you're small.
I think it's for the rock soup.
I think if you shrink me and I do rock soup, I just...
Ew, look at it, Twitch.
Look at it twitching.
Do you see it twitching?
No, I think it's only on your screen.
Oh.
Let me drink you.
Okay.
Wow.
Do you see it wiggling?
Alright, let's go.
Let's go to the...
Let's go to the goblin village.
Oh, okay, that's fine too.
Here's your divine light, Lymo.
And your Excalibur.
No, no, I'm not...
I want Excalibur.
No, no, no, no.
Look at that Excalibur.
I'll trade you.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
There you go.
Oh, thank you.
Be small.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Wait, what?
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to make you tiny.
Wait, I don't know how to...
Am I sure...
Am I tall?
Yes.
You are now.
Oh, okay.
Do you want to be small?
Oh, thank you.
You're welcome.
They're in the forest, but...
Oh my gosh, even the map is big.
What is this?
What?
Hey, why are you guys so small?
We've been smallening each other.
Okay, now I'm big.
Okay, let's go to the goblin village and grab more spells.
Wow.
Does it work?
Follow the sound of the children.
Follow the sound!
Wow.
Have you guys seen the goblins?
The goblins.
I think it's the bottom one.
That's where the goblins village.
Let's go find them.
It's the...
It's at the bottom.
So it should be the right side The right side this way this way yeah, yeah Oh, it's gonna be this way It should be I don't know why we're trusting Wait, there's a sign.
Oh, this is a tree.
I thought it was a sign That's the swamp I don't think we have it this time.
Yeah, we can get inside the fireplace though you guys i didn't find it down here i think it is it north did anybody see north why does it say the rock golem and mushroom man follow wherever you go on the map yeah i said that i noticed that too mushroom man i crafted the mushroom man before it says still still is a powerful way to use extra resources the spore frog how do we get more frogs you have to kill the frogs oh i hear one i hear Use the smite!
Use the sword!
But don't get eaten!
Oh...
Wait...
Don't get eaten!
Help me out!
No,
don't do that!
Don't do that!
Get Excalibur eaten!
I can't get out!
Excalibur eaten by a frog is pretty iconic.
Oh...
Can you imagine he eats Excalibur and just like...
combusts from inside?
Hey buddy, grab my hand!
Missin' stuck in the swamp!
Please!
Please don't stuck!
It happens if you like regain stamina for a bit.
Okay.
I'm not regaining stamina.
Shops are like immune to damage, bro.
Maybe, yeah.
Can you get out here?
There's a slope here.
Okay, let me try that.
Are you sinking lower?
No, I'm not.
Wait, there's a frog right there!
I'm out, I'm out!
Yay!
Oh, wait.
Guys.
Oh, no.
Wait a minute.
It'll be fine.
Log lift.
Oh, I got it.
Oh, I did it.
All right.
Oh, the frog disappeared.
Oh.
You gotta find a frog so we can...
Divine line.
Yay!
I hear one.
Are we killing a frog?
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, yeah, we're killing a frog.
Oh.
Oh, she didn't make it.
Oh, I'm forgiving, isn't it?
Oh.
Yeah.
Wait, I killed one.
And it dropped a bird.
Oh.
We didn't even crack you.
I can't even get around.
Okay, here we go.
There's a slope behind you.
You can probably get back up there.
This one?
I got the toad and made a raster.
Yeah.
Oh, oh.
Fireball.
That's definitely dead.
I think so.
Oh, there he is!
Fireball.
I got it.
Do we just keep going?
I got a frog and spawns a frog where they- Oh my god.
He's right behind us.
Fireball.
There are so many.
There's so many.
Fireball.
Fireball!
Just a bunch of wizards like exterminating the whole- Where are you going?
Yeah, I saw it happen.
Oh shit, shit, shit, shit, shoot, shoot, shoot!
Fireball!
we're so in sync i think we leave there's like more and more frogs showing up yeah they're getting angry oh go go go
fireballs around honestly how can our spells still be growing stronger that's crazy oh you know i think we're finished now but i didn't get anything from the frogs did you uh snuffy said she got a frog so maybe she's making something cool i'm going home we can go into the lava castle oh okay it'll be fun yeah i want to go in there i just couldn't figure out how to get in i think you gotta parkour it oh i see the path okay yeah oh watch out watch out oh watch out oh shit other than the god we have to i think we have to reset the map oh god goblin island oh why am i Why am I slipping?
Oh, why am I slipping?
Oh, why am I...
You got parkour.
Oh, it's the evil being you.
Oh, shit.
Is it...
Oh, my God.
Who are you?
She is evil.
Ah!
There's so many of them.
Oh, my God.
Ah!
Oh, where's your spider?
Fireball.
Go, please.
I thought it was...
would have been up first.
Yeah, she did.
Oh, she gave you the...
Oh, my gosh.
Hold on, I'm gonna take a voice.
I'm too much screaming in this game.
Too much craziness.
Where am I?
Oh.
I didn't know that there were guys in there.
Oh, we're back here.
Maybe I can get a frog.
my spells grow stronger all right i'm gonna get a frog and i'm gonna eat it i'm gonna make frog soup
oh what the hell was that
what the hell was that this also has to do And the curse of the heavens.
Oh, that was Excalibur, wasn't it?
I think maybe that's Lymu killing the people.
Go, Lymu, go!
Did you get it?
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
For now, yeah.
Did you do it?
Maybe one of the other towers has more?
See, maybe.
Oh my god, I didn't get up here.
There's towers?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, spiral staircases.
Okay, I'm going.
Hey, there's another one.
What's in the now water?
I'm going up.
I don't know.
Come touch it.
I'm running out of space.
Okay, I'll loot it.
Got a torn page.
Blake.
Where are you guys?
Uh, dark blast.
Okay.
Did I get anybody?
It was, um, let's get out of here.
It sucks here, and I think Doki Bird got a new spell.
Teleported into the lava and died?
I don't know.
Oh, fuck, God.
I'm so unlucky.
Let's get out.
Yeah, let's go.
Fireball.
Doki run.
I got a new spell.
Oh, what'd you get?
What'd you get?
I'll use it on Doki.
Okay.
You can hear her just freaking out in there.
Doki, follow the sound of- What the- So if I say her name it-
Follow the sound of our voice!
Come here, Doki!
We're outside!
Special beam cannon or something.
Kamehameha or some- We're outside!
Turn around!
Outside the lava!
We're outside!
Oh!
This thing is dangerous!
What does blink do?
It makes you zip.
Oh.
Be careful using it because you might go straight into the lava.
Oh, I didn't take your weed of the pie, but...
They'll eventually leave that castle, right?
Huh?
They'll eventually leave the castle, right?
Are you guys coming outside?
What is that sound?
Oh, like new stuff too?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Whoa.
You should come outside.
Wait, wait, wait.
Give me a sec.
I'm double checking this area.
Okay.
What new stuff?
What new spells?
What is that noise?
I don't...
What?
noise yeah yeah what was that dark blast
oh my god that's cool oh it took I took credit for the kill why oh she got wait She got something.
What'd she get?
Whisp.
Oh, that's the bullshit.
That, like, tracked me across the fucking map and killed me.
That's my little guy.
Yeah.
Don't forget your dark blast.
I don't think Doki's going to be very happy with you.
Oh, no.
I got the dark blast.
Oh, what's this one then?
Oh, is it blink?
Yeah.
I guess I'll take it, so in case I need to run.
She's over there.
I hear her.
No.
What the fuck am I supposed to be?
You took my sweat and sweat down me.
Hello?
Dark Blast.
Oh my god, it's a...
Oh my god, it's a wisp spell.
I kept...
You took my sweat.
Whisp.
Whisp?
Oh, it's supposed to be right.
There we go.
That's right.
Fireball.
Thunderbolt.
Not me!
Where'd they go?
I just hear the tiny thunderbolt.
Dark blast.
What does it do?
I'm dying to myself?
Wait, where is he?
How did I die?
No, she's gonna take all my stuff.
Oh.
How'd you die?
I got eaten by a frog.
I was trying to craft a crystal frog.
I don't know what they're gonna do.
How do you do that?
Fireball.
Oh, I heard him.
I heard him die, I think.
You think we actually got him?
Oh gosh, I'm out.
Uh, uh, oh no.
I'll get out.
Don't worry about me.
I'll figure it away.
Good job, Lymo.
.
Fireball.
I think that was him.
Oh, oh, oh.
He sounds close.
Oh, there he is.
Fireball.
How do you get him?
Like he sounds dying.
Who goes there?
How many people can play in these lobbies?
Gotta arc it.
Thought that was something.
Why am I leveling up still?
Oh, I thought I wasn't gonna make that, guys.
Get out!
No!
Luckily I didn't have anything.
Ha!
I wish the game had a little bit more.
Like more things to explore and uncover.
I'm stuck in the mountains.
Like, uh, kind of like, like, you have the mausoleum.
You have the fire castle.
Is there anything else?
Hmm.
Is this our home?
Home sweet home?
Oh, this guy's just been leaving rocks for us.
Guys, if I make the rock soup, what should I say?
For everybody to know.
You can ask questions at the magic mirror.
Mirror mirror.
How are you?
Yeah.
I didn't say anything.
Hello?
It's like a magic eight ball.
No.
No, not snub!
Yeah, no, no snub!
Oh, okay.
I'm going to say something to the world.
okay
guys just pretend that i'm in like mid conversation okay with you guys okay
okay all right so she's like down on her luck and then she decides that she's going to join this farm the minotaur milking farm and basically it's exactly what it sounds like with the minotars they need to get milked because they just i guess They just build up too much in their,
you know, and the girl really likes balls, so...
Hello!
I'm here for the Minotaur milk and water!
Oh my god, oh my god, a toad!
Wait, yes!
Wait!
Is that a frog right there?
This isn't my rave toad?
What the fuck is this?
done what is that thing underneath oh i got the toad what does it do oh what is that
oh oh my gosh i'm going backwards oh my gosh if i press forwards i go backwards oh i've drugged you with my toad intoxications holy how'd you make that i put a crystal and a toad Wait, what if I put a toad and a log together?
Oh, toad stick.
Toad, wait, that is...
The toad stick was something.
What does it do, though?
There's toad, toad, toad crystal, toad rock, and toad rock again.
Your pseudonym toad plus rock.
How can you read this?
For frogla fire blade.
Frog balloon?
If it's frog frog.
Frog.
Try frog rock.
That sounds promising.
I think that was in the tutorial or something, but I don't remember what it did.
Yeah, the log, frog log or something.
Yeah.
What?
Frog stick.
But I can't read what it does.
Can you?
Oh, the elevator.
Okay, frog stick does...
Where...
Special the...
square frog tequila and designer bread of sponge i think that's what it said When exposed the...
The...
Oh!
They're killing each other.
I'm crafting, I'm just, I'm studying the science while they're too busy crafting.
Okay, it's time.
It's done him the sorcery.
What is it?
What does it do to you?
Nothing.
Wait, hold on.
Let me try grabbing.
No?
What does it do?
Wait, hold it out?
Just hold it?
I try, but it...
Oh, here we go.
But it has like a timer.
I don't know what it does.
It steals held items.
I don't think so.
Oh!
You took it.
I did.
But I dropped.
But I didn't take it.
Wait, let me try.
Oh, it makes you drop it.
Oh, you disarm people.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
We're upgrading our wizard game.
You're so much.
Try your book.
Oh, my book.
You can steal my book?
That would be crazy.
Oh my god!
Wait, that's a game changer.
Wait, wait, can you take it?
Hold on, take it again.
Can you just take it out of my inventory and pick it up?
Uh, no, I can't pick it up.
Dang.
Be a little OP.
That is scary.
Even without my tomes, my tomes.
I know!
How'd you make the frog gun?
The crystal and frog.
Oh, crystal frog.
Crystal.
Any frog?
Ah, nice.
Thank you.
Crystal and frog.
Oh, I just took your gut or your materials.
Ink.
Thank you.
I like the way it sounds.
It sounds like a squishy toy.
Yeah.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, I'm back to normal.
Frog plus frog.
Let's see if we can find them.
Wait, this is the frog balloon.
Wait, yeah, yeah.
Are you gonna float?
Where are you?
Oh, there she goes!
I can't.
Oh, right, I'm poison.
I have to move this way.
Goodbye, Mint.
Goodbye!
I'm the Mary Poppins of Wizards!
Does it work?
Do I just have terrible aim?
I think you have bad aim.
Aw, man.
Hey, Doki.
What do you mean we'll never know?
I'm wearing like a little spinner hat while I'm holding my fucking balloon right now.
Like, I feel like so...
What do you mean we'll never know?
You'll never know.
Wait, give me a second.
I'm trying to get the sword back.
I'll be right back.
What do you mean the sword?
Try to get the sword back.
I don't think she knows where I died.
I have that in.
Did she get the sword?
Where are you?
Wait, I'm here.
What is that?
Let me use it on you.
Oh wait.
What is that?
What did you do?
That does.
I know what that does.
I know it.
I'm finding it.
That was not the sword the first time.
No!
That's when you get back here.
Get back here.
Are you bullying me again?
Yeah!
She bullied me!
Where'd you drop it?
I don't know where it is.
That's a tree.
You did it.
Wait, what'd you...
Oh, I like your blue frog.
Thank you.
That looks cool.
Wait, why am I purple?
Oh, I'm backwards.
Why am I backwards?
I hate that.
Why am I purple?
Somebody needs to play a little time out, Missy.
I made them purple.
Oh!
Wait, I like this area.
Guys, I think I missed.
What haven't we claimed?
Can I try?
Fireball.
Nice.
What's happening?
Free!
Fireball.
Oh, she died?
Nice.
I love freezing.
My frog balloon!
I don't have divine light anymore.
I'm gonna go make a frog balloon.
Did somebody miss their tone?
Nikki!
I wanna make one too!
Oh.
Why is that here?
It was Frog Frog, right?
They keep bringing us stuff, so...
Oh, I didn't mean to drop that.
Frog Frog.
Uh, E-G-E-G-E-G.
We have one frog.
The little children will bring more.
I don't think...
I don't see one.
in there just see rocks everywhere hold on i'm gonna ask for the i'm gonna ask the children
i don't know why i'm getting so strong i desire frog please give me frog frog i desire the frog give me the frog i desire the frog Little children with frog.
Give me the frog.
Okay, that should work.
Imagine if they could still hear me right now.
That'd be embarrassing.
Ribbit.
Rock plus crystal.
Let's try it.
Oh, the child.
Oh my god, he listened!
Wow!
Oh my god!
Hello?
I'm bringing you a frog.
You found the frog?
Yeah.
The child brought me one actually.
We have all so many supplies over here.
It's crazy.
Thank you though.
Thank you.
No problem.
I like how you guys gathered a ton of supplies.
Meanwhile, I just like hunkered down Doki like seven times in a row or something.
That's good too.
to figure it out each quadrant on the map if you press q each biome represents a simple material like rock crystal or frog i guess in wood so if you capture it goblins will passively bring these see them coming behind doki they will just passively bring you all these items yeah so while you capture it they'll just keep taking you frogs and rocks so that's how you get into what is this guy doing crystals at me i'm going to leave
That's cool.
This guy keeps fucking throwing stuff at me.
Yeah?
He's a bad boy.
No, he's not.
He's my child.
He's a bad boy.
He's a bad child.
Oh, wow.
Oh, my God.
No more children in the workplace.
No, no, my child, please.
Let me have him please, please.
I'm going to go put him into the ocean.
I think he'll follow.
Yeah, kill the child.
Don't kill my child.
Yeah.
Can I fly over the ocean?
Oh, little baby.
Go.
He has, like, an ASMR sound when he walks.
Like, rock moving?
You like that?
Yeah.
Does your ears feel good?
Yeah, it does.
Here, I'll take him.
I'll take him so he can follow me here.
Alright.
Follow me, child.
Oh, yeah.
Ice age, ASMR.
Yeah, yeah.
Follow me, little guy.
What if I go up?
Yeah, you've been killing them, but they're useful.
No, yeah, but when you kill them, they still drop the stuff regardless.
Look at my child, he's coming.
See you, watch this.
Wait, what?
All right, let's reset the map.
Oh, my God.
Wait, wait, what happened?
My frog balloon!
Oopsie.
What happened?
Oh, new lobby says Doki.
Okay.
Oh, I almost leaked it.
I almost leaked the lobby.
I don't think you guys would have enough time to join them.
Probably?
Maybe.
He's an orphan.
Hello?
Like a trigger for these games is like, I hate when little game, little indie games pop off so good.
They have so much potential.
But then it's just like they're tiny indie games.
They're tiny little projects.
So you never get like a further update.
Staring at you, web fishing.
See, see.
Thank you so much for this over there.
I'm sorry that I have two clams on your birthday, but happy birthday!
There's a magic mirror on the wall.
Happy, happy birthday!
Hi!
Yeah.
Is anyone else unmuted?
Wait, what is she trying to draw Homer Simpson if it was Doki Bird?
Okay, just me.
That's a...
Is that supposed to be me?
Is anyone else unmuted?
Just me?
Oh, I'll join the Sorcerers.
Me and Lymo.
Me and... Why are they lackeys still?
We're novices.
Clearly...
Clearly they are not doing a great job.
only me only i want to talk to my friends only i was unmuted oh wait edit the team flag i forgot what this is so cute i love dinosaur i'm gonna make him green
very carefully me me me me me me me Wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, wee, oh.
Wee, wee, wee, wee, wee.
It's a ferret.
Oh, it's like a broken surface.
I see it.
Oh.
Uh,
what's, what's the plan here?
I think we're going to see if they, uh, they, uh, have a village now oh yeah I'm feeling if we don't then they're just going to or Doki's gonna reroll them out oh okay
oh what's a fungus soup let's try it please make me a soup
that's blue beautiful blue soup yeah bottoms up my joints feel like rubber Oh, I just hop!
Oh, you're bouncy!
That's cool.
What if I have my stick, too?
Whoa!
Insane distance!
Unhitable.
Do we have... Oh.
Um...
I don't think we have the village again.
No, maybe not.
Yeah, it doesn't look like it.
Yeah, we have the mountain, the woods, the fire castle, the bouncy shrooms, festivals, creepy cemetery, and what's the top one, top metal?
I think that's a swamp.
Oh.
Yeah.
Maybe Dookie should be rolling again?
Oh, no, sleepy.
He's tired.
Contagious yawn.
I am always yawning.
How long does the soup last for?
I have no idea.
Is there anything special in this area?
Like, it feels very...
lackluster it's kind of whatever yeah some areas are like yeah this is just a dead forest i guess we can go to their base and then be like okay didn't get the village again yeah oh
uh this is a dead end oh this is just everest yeah if you go around through the creepy cemetery
Where are we?
Okay.
Hello?
I can hear them yelling.
Okay.
Is Doki a bird?
Oh, they're talking to the mirror.
A Doki bird.
Hey, guys.
Hi.
We're using the mirror.
Yeah.
Wait, what happened?
We didn't spawn, so...
Oh, did the village spawn?
No, I didn't.
How do you know?
There's like so many things.
We checked on the map.
The swamp, Mount Everest, the fire castle.
Oh, that's the swamp.
Yeah, the top is the swamp.
Okay.
Do you want that slide?
No!
Fireball.
The sound's just as stupid when you say it.
Oh my god, no.
Everybody be nice.
I'm putting that in a cloud.
Oh my god.
She killed.
Fireball.
Ah.
I thought we were gonna respawn though.
I thought we were gonna...
Oh wait.
so there's really nothing in here if I die I didn't oh okay yeah we're re-rolling we're re-rolling how did we get the village I think like the first two times okay new lobby new lobby sorry we're trying to spawn a certain a certain whatever it's called map
fireball fireball Oh,
uh, okay.
I'm getting sleepy, though.
Oh,
we...
Uh, okay, here we go.
What should we make our flag?
Oh, I'll join the sorcerer.
Um, what should we make our flag, guys?
What should we make our flag?
I'm gonna make it on my little hat.
like this and like this and then blue blue blue blue blue wait blue blue blue blue blue white erase erase and we'll do like the lighter blue down here This is looking pretty good.
It's a wizard's hat.
Wizard's hat.
It's a bust of magic, right?
Yeah, that's all you, Fireball.
Oh, she drew a lime!
And then little stars.
Oh my god, my cat!
Pause!
Why are you in here?
Thanks.
little wizards.
Hold on, I gotta let my cat out real quick.
Thank you, Duke.
That middle biome looks new.
Welcome all sorcerers and warlocks to the mage arena.
May the best wizard win and let the games begin.
Oh, that's how you do that.
Oh, it is the village?
Hell yeah, finally.
Wait, oh right, because that's coming out
What I miss nothing I was waiting for you.
What's in the wait is that it in the middle?
Yeah, I think so let's go
Everest It's so weird it doesn't play full Oh man.
Oh, oh man.
Okay, you got it.
We're fine.
Everything's good.
I like can't, oh my gosh.
Oh, oh.
Which is a new global emote they just uploaded and it's like snake running along with the box on top of them.
What?
Yeah.
They uploaded that as a global?
Yeah, I guess for the release.
and sorcerers.
Hello.
No, wait, I just gave him my book.
Wait, I think I messed up.
He traded your book for one crystal.
He traded me a log for a log.
He got me a rock?
He gave me a lot?
He gave me a magic spell.
I got a spell too.
Oh god.
Hoor.
That's okay, man.
You don't need magic.
Divine light.
Wait, I got two spells.
Wait, I got one called rock!
No, just let me die!
That was my spell.
Just let me die!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna cast it over here because it sounds scary.
Oh, that spell.
What a spell.
Oh, yeah.
It looks like we killed Doki with last round.
She likes that spell.
You should show it to her.
Which one?
It's the rock.
Oh.
Rock.
It has a very long cooldown, though.
Say it again.
Oh.
Rock.
Oh, if you stand on top of it, you can go high up.
Oh, that's crazy.
Does the rock despawn?
I got this one.
Dark blast.
Well, you put her out.
to her misery.
I've been put out of my misery.
Guys, I can't believe I sold my book.
I got my book back.
Yippee!
What was that?
Don't lose it again.
No promises.
Wait, where are they?
I want to trade things that are not my book.
Wait.
Where am I?
I need to go
This way?
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm eating chicken nuggets.
I got some.
I got my book back.
I will get back.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I tried to blow her up with the laser beam.
Yeah.
And I was like so far away.
You can have, wait.
I can have this.
Thank you.
Whisp.
So it said whisp.
Ah!
That's, that's, that's, that's, that's, that's, okay.
Ouch, my legs.
Oh, that's because I'm light.
Whisp.
Wisp.
We can't finish the stream until you get the Wisp off.
I don't think it does damage, so I don't think it'll kill us if it does.
Wisp.
I'm trying to like, oh my god, we killed them all.
Oh my god, you murdered them!
Oh my god!
Whisp.
What is it?
Order 63 or something?
Whisp, Whisp, Whisp, Whisp, Whisp, Whisp.
Whisp.
Mine and blast.
Order 66.
I can say mine and blast, but Mince can't say whisp 100 times about a person.
Whisp.
Is it broken?
Okay, do it to us, Clem.
See if we can do it.
Try it.
Let's try.
Whisp.
I think I gave you a dud spell.
Should I try?
Whisp.
You guys hate me.
It worked for me before.
Whisp.
Okay.
I can't do it.
Someone else do it.
Whisp.
Your turn.
Wisp!
It just looked nasty, I'm sorry.
Divinely.
What was it?
I'm just gonna go W, try more on the S&P?
Wisp.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, what are you focused on?
Wisp.
You try?
Yeah, it's like a rock.
A rock.
Whisp.
Oh, mine's dead.
Is it dead?
I can tell.
Divine light.
Yeah.
It's still, I can tell.
It's like, it's like a whipped cream, like.
Whisp.
Go fast.
Try faster.
Whisp.
There you go.
Yeah, yeah.
What the fuck does this spell even do?
I don't know.
It's like a very small amount of trash to your enemies or something.
Yeah.
Divine light.
behind someone.
Thank you.
Divine light.
I can't try to snipe them out of the sky.
Whisp.
Oh, it slows you down a little too.
Okay, I think spells gives me such power.
I really do think.
Yeah.
Have you guys ever larped like IRL?
Oh my god, no.
it's very similar to this i haven't done it in real life but i remember when i was a kid all the kids that like pokemon and dragon ball would like run around the playground shouting attack names and stuff and acting it out with their bodies yeah yeah A sorcerer has been slain.
Two sorcerers have been slain.
I kind of saw that.
Oh,
I just saw Limu spawn over there.
Limu!
Oh!
I mean, I could get everything in here.
Hi, man.
Hi!
Oh.
I'm trying to get some more spells.
Do you want to kill Doki together and then stop?
Yeah, that sounds good.
Oh, well, um, hold on.
I think I'm about to die.
Please don't die.
Don't die.
I'd miss you.
Oh, yeah.
Ah.
Alright.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, hey.
Let's kill her.
Okay.
I hear her.
Yeah.
Our words with blast and...
Thumb blast.
Fireball.
The firelight.
Missile.
Oh, not fireball.
Very good.
Yay!
Oh, I want my stuff back.
Where'd it go?
Why does Doki have an orb?
What is that?
I saw her holding it.
Yeah, I don't know.
Consult the orb.
Oh, can we combine it?
Oh, it does.
I don't know.
You can touch it.
Grasp orb.
Whoa.
Founder it.
I'm going to go home and I'm going to use it.
Okay.
Oh, no, we're stuck.
What is that?
Flying into the sky.
Wow.
Hello?
Hi!
What?
Who's in the sky?
I- I saw someone in the sky!
Doesn't do anything.
Make it a soup, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Make me an ingredient, and I'll make you a powerful magical soup.
Yeah, yeah, soup the orb, soup the orb.
I want to consume the orb, please.
I don't know what to- wait!
I'm seeing someone's POV.
Wait, that's kind of cool.
If I...
Their warlocks have captured the crystal caverns.
Whoa!
Oh.
Um, we were supposed to stop playing the game.
by look wait am i seeing limeu's vision limeu vision where am i even i have no idea okay i'm gonna go this way right yes indeed
hello hello that's me that's me hey We're here!
Oh, they're all back!
Oh, they did come back.
They're here.
Oh, they did!
Dark Blast.
Oh my god!
You killed the guy!
What did he do to you?
Dookie can't leave no one to trade anymore because you killed his friend.
Wait, Dookie, did you ponder the orb?
Yeah, I pondered the orb.
You can basically like stream snipe up the enemy.
Yeah, it's crazy.
Yeah.
I mean, I could just pull up your stream instead, but like, yeah, it's pretty...
Oh, I mean, that takes a lot of effort, I think.
Whisp.
What did you do?
That was the Whisp.
Oh, that was the Whisp.
The Whisp.
Sending out the Whisp.
Do we want to call it here?
Wait.
I think that's all the stealthy one last train.
Yeah, seems like it.
Yeah, that works for me.
One last spell trade.
They won't give me anything but they and frogs.
They just give me mushrooms.
I wish we did not kill the majority of these people.
Hidden blast.
What was that?
It's just a dark glass.
Oh.
Dark glass.
Close.
I think you guys were like, I think you missed a goblin.
Oh!
Yes, please!
Hey, give me the thing!
Dark blast.
Fireball.
It was collateral damage.
My bad.
There are all dead oh my god she's so loud he's like muted her
they'll come back in the night time they sleep and they're just asleep they're nocturnal they're nocturnal night bears oh whoa Oh my god, he's like, no, no, don't do it.
No, no, no.
He's like living the same day every day.
It's one.
Dark Blast.
Lincoln Doki, a dark Blast each.
Oh, I'm sorry.
They have to 1v1.
Russian, we're left.
I hope the dark Blast all gets tight in a circle together and we all just fireball each other, like fireball into the center together.
Right now?
Okay.
We are here.
Okay, new idea?
We should be like a skewered.
two dark blasts on the end simultaneously just like entail us all together wait what oh yeah yeah okay i have dark blast oops sorry
wait hold on mine needs to recharge yeah that's fine what works some blast yeah okay okay are you ready man no It's gotta...
It's gotta reload.
Okay.
I'm good.
All right.
I'm ready.
On one.
Three, two, one.
Dark Blast.
Woo!
It worked!
Yeah!
Oh.
Yay!
I'm gonna, I guess, I guess so we can say bye, we'll jump into Discord.
Yeah, I guess Discord will be better.
Yeah, okay.
Okay, bye, man.
Bye, Lymoor.
I leave game.
I go to Discord.
Good.
Hello?
Anybody else on Discord?
I have unmuted everybody.
Can anyone else hear me yet?
I can hear you.
Yay.
Oh, there's the floor.
fucking around i think oh my god wait we're dead dead for oh wait no no matter how many times i try and escape this magical hell it keeps me in i'll tp back tp girl get out of the game they're never leaving they're they're obsessed they're fixated we've seen everything you can see of the game oh yeah but like if they teleport again it'd be really funny oh yeah and drown
together and just drown ourselves oh that's fair that sounds that sounds beautiful mint and i we just said goodbye like normal people yeah yeah we had passion in our deaths oh okay we went out like vikings wizards but vikings yeah yeah we have a viking we had a viking funeral They caught in there.
That was fun.
That was fun exploring everything.
That was really, really fun.
Thank you for inviting me.
Updates to it.
I hope it updates more.
More tools and shit.
I want emotes.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
More spells.
More spells would be really cool.
I thought that it was developed by one guy.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Like, It'd be cool to have like a horse.
or like a broomstick a broomstick you just rode right up on your horse and just go fireball and then ride away you could do that with the frog balloon yeah that's so true okay that was okay the anti-air shit of all three of you guys like he's shooting fireballs in place does that mean this guy I literally I saw you in the distance and i thought you were like just having fun and like trying to like like you know my eyes when i saw you i saw goki like flying in the air and you guys shooting off fireballs and i was like oh my god look they're trying to shoot off fire expert doki oh my god then i get closer it's definitely what we were doing yeah yeah and then you joined in and was like freeze and i was like what i think that was the funniest thing about that game is that sometimes it felt like more of a mafia game where two wizards just turn the corner like fireball like no you didn't hear them coming up behind you yeah just hear it simultaneously like we got you turn around we were
trying to get rid of the evidence and then you and like libel and mitt were like fireball fireball yeah it's so good like because you have to be so monotone it's like execution style remorseless.
Did you guys flag that?
It kind of felt like a paintball game.
Like that's gotta feel like what it was.
Like fucking paintball.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's like we got, there was a hit on us there.
I'm surprised I can't hear you guys' footsteps, so it would literally just be suddenly this like villainous approach.
Yeah.
Sneak attack.
Goodbye, snuff me and Doki.
You're gonna sleep with the fishes to now Oh my god, are you kidding me?
It might have just done Doki V everybody.
I can't get over the game, though.
We're live who had six kills on us.
It was all bad.
No, I don't understand.
It was like, we have no British support.
I feel like there was no American support.
Clearly, the way to be like, you know, like Celestial in that fucking game is to have an American-British hybrid accent.
That's the key.
Yeah, like, everything.
most wizard tone.
Every word you say, the game registers.
And then it took Min and I like five times to say one thing.
I never liked my fireball.
I don't know why.
Yeah, I would be like fireball and it would just be like, nah.
I would be like fireball.
Then she shoots like seven fireballs at us.
Go back to Hogwarts, idiot.
Love you, son.
You gotta repeat your first.
It's fireball, not fireball.
I think I know who's a Hufflepuff here.
isn't it?
Is there any English learner is trying to play this game?
Oh my gosh.
The first time we will practice on British English.
Aluminum.
Aluminium.
That's what it is.
You're going to be out here going 40 water bottles in my aluminium cup.
All approximately 30 degrees Celsius.
oh god it's looking hot no thank you the warmest water it's a hot day outside i don't know i wonder if the game would register my voice more if i put it on indian mode i think i think another streamer had to do that so maybe oh my like for different languages and stuff they have like there's like an act there's like a different they have like an accent you could change the game um to like to like indian english oh Oh,
Indian accent.
That's kind of cool.
I feel like I have a vocal support.
Yeah, you guys don't really, like, strike me as people with, like, I mean, like, we all have different ways of speaking, but I didn't say, like, accent.
Yeah.
I think it was just weird, because even me for Fireball, I have, like, people say I have a Midwestern accent.
I have to be like, a Midwestern accent.
A child would probably say so.
They'll be like, oh, yeah, I can hear that from Snuffy, and I'll just stand up.
they're like, what does that mean?
What does midwestern accidentally... Wait, they say...
Oh.
What?
Midwestern.
No, I have no idea.
Oh.
Oh, oh.
Yeah, it's still Fireball.
Don't you know.
Yeah, I know Mint.
I know Mint has played Lifeline, but has Doki yet?
Doki, have you played Lifeline yet?
Oh, my God.
No, Doki, you need to play Lifeline.
Nope, you need to play lifeline i was like lifeline from apex like no yeah no it's like a really old game with voice it's like it's a voice controlled ps2 game and that that game will make you doubt the way that you say any words ever in the english language it will just make you feel like you're just speaking a completely different language oh oh i did that with hey you pikachu and pikachu made me feel like I was schizophrenic.
Like literally nothing on my side.
He just stared at me.
I tried to play that fish game.
What was it the, where you raise a human fish face guy?
Oh my God, yeah, I've seen that.
Yeah, yeah.
What's that?
It did not work.
For some reason, I could not get the microphone to work.
And then I just raised all the fish and then I just let all the fishes die in the table.
Oh, please.
Yeah, that was Sea Man, I think.
That's like a real, yeah, it was Sea Man in like 1999.
Yeah.
i was trying to like get them to talk to me but they refused to like like acknowledge me and then i was like fine i'll just starve all of you to death i'm gonna post a picture you guys might have seen this this is seaman 1999.
it's a game of human fish people oh beautiful whoa and you talk to them yeah he grows into a he grows into a fucking lizard i would be so rude to him Not the lizard.
No, he's ugly.
A freak.
He is a freak.
What if that's the devs face?
Somebody said they poop out of their dangler.
Oh, it's a dangler.
Did you see like how they mate?
Wait, the human fish?
I think he's the only one who's actually played the game.
Oh god.
here oh no don't say here don't say here slide something your way it's like avatar dude are they wait wait just on the thumbnail are they doing it doggy it looks like it well can i pull this up two seaman i'm not putting i'm not putting that on stream he's a better version he's a better oh no sega dreamcast seaman game mating footage you're looking this is in your history
I'm not booting that on stream check and look that up I'm gonna give the link to you guys you can watch it there we go yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna just post that link in chat it's more like a mosquito I think there's two videos because Doki's really into it
it reminds me have you ever seen the old movie uh it's called slither it has like um she linked The second video.
It has, like, Merle from the Walking Dead in it.
And he kind of does that, like, when he has that whole thing with the weird, like, tube thing, and it, like, for reproduction, and you kind of just brought back a really horrible memory.
Thank you.
Wait.
Oh, I do know this.
Yeah, it's like, it's like, Merle from the Walking Dead and Nathan Fillion.
Merle and Nathan Fillion?
Yeah.
What movie is it called?
Slither.
Yeah.
At one point a woman blows up with like little slug creatures and then explodes.
Yeah, yeah.
Gosh, I haven't seen that.
2006.
Oh, it's from James Gunn.
Oh my god.
I like James Gunn.
There we go.
His name is Michael Brooker so I can start calling him Mom.
You could be in the next slither.
No.
No, thank you.
Yeah.
Sign me up.
i'll be inflated with what that's what you said and i'm not no i'm gonna go eat my dinner thanks snuffy yeah oh yeah by the way chat before we decided on mage arena there was another game that i brought up oh my god it was called what was it bogus binted it was a yeah oh my god bogus binted even bogus binted bogus binted are we booting this one up and then i was like guys should play bogos binted guys and and then min was like why don't how about majorina i no i don't i don't think i suggested major it was my suggestion yeah no it's not even just bogos binted it's bogos binted with a question mark and it's oh right right it's liar's game liar's bar with aliens but basically yeah with like four other game modes yeah it literally looks like such nonsense like that or the wizard game yeah i think that's cool like italian really funny game yeah chat this was the game that i first suggested before we pivoted italian it has like italian brain rot memes in it i think and stuff what italian
brain rot memes yeah you know like what
Oh, I don't know.
You don't know them all by name, dude.
You don't know the famous Italian.
Yeah.
What?
No, but like, where do you see it in the game?
Oh, I don't know.
i thought i thought it was in there booted it up and tried it out she played the tutorial she was ready dedicated yeah i made the game that's what if it wasn't like an impossible ask i think it would be so funny if we like made each other games to play in some sort of shitty way that would be so funny i wish i wish it was that easy i was gonna say men made bogos binnet the developer's name was bad badger stop doxing my my alter ego from bad badger than so yeah yep ggs guys thank you very much everyone have a good night yeah it was fun casting spells with you it was fun you still streaming i will i will okay i'll send my my people your way then i would send it to you other guys but you're on youtube so much you know what i'm i'm calling it open up some more tabs chat that's fair that's my endurance is very low you would be surprised though i mean give yourself more credit working as hard as a streamer i mean that's that's like funny people will be like duh play games but you do do a lot
others than just like going live so you know yeah you're right Maybe I'll stream Marvel Rivals later on Twitch Maybe to yourself Maybe you could play Like a little kind of creature Yeah, bye, I'm
leaving too Bye-bye Guys, I'm so sleepy I'm so tired I don't know why Oh my gosh, this game made me be like I got slopped I got slopped I got slopped Oh, wait.
I don't think I should say this on stream yet.
Let me actually message the girls.
The sloppy girls.
Uh.
Hold on.
Just maybe in an addition to the sloppy sisters.
Maybe.
I think maybe I need to finish my dinner.
So that's what I'm going to go do.
And I need to go blow my nose.
I have no tissue.
I have no tissue, so I'm like...
But this was a lot of fun.
Thank you guys for the Mage Arena.
This was silliness.
Silly, silly, silly, silly.
And tomorrow, um, tomorrow, tomorrow, half-life.
More half-life.
Yippee.
Yippee, yippee.
And then MGScon, if I see you there, I'll see you.
not if you're going to other things enjoy that as well and also listen to the cover thank you guys for the super just thank you thank you my brain is very slow right now so i'm just gonna go i'm just gonna um sleep not sleep i have things to do but i'm gonna go rest and eat okay bye-bye bye-bye Bye-bye!